are you a big reader massive give me a
few books that influenced you okay so I
would say hypomanic Edge it's not a
famous book made me realize it's okay
that I'm wired the way I am hypomanic
would kind of give you an idea of how
the individuals are what they buil it
talks about craziness in business and
massive success something like that it's
an older book I like barbarians to
bureaucrats good luck finding it but he
talks about the evolution of every
society that they go through with the
prophet to Barbarian to Builder Explorer
administrator to bureaucrat Aristocrat
and then a just comes to save that
Society fantastic book I would put 33
Strategies of War by my good friend
Robert Green phenomenal book highly
highly recommend it Blue Ocean strategy
on how to separate yourself from the
marketplace if you really want to figure
out a way to separate yourself from
everybody else you got to read blue
ocean of success psycho cybernetics
power versus for but one that I just
read that I recommend everybody reading
is unreasonable Hospitality by Will
gadera good luck putting that book down
it's incredible